now
you're obviously uh you obviously have a
lot of money that might not necessarily
be rap money
um what like
what would you you know there's
up-and-coming artists
who make mistakes who
you know yeah got one foot in one foot
out you know what i'm saying like
you seem to be doing very well for
yourself and you seem to be fully
entrenched in the rap game now but what
would be some advice you would give
to some uh up and coming artists that
might be watching this that might kind
of
you know still have one foot in the
streets one foot out like you know what
i'm saying like what yeah
oh basically i tell them just invest
their money like don't be cheap like
you know i'm saying don't be like if
you're gonna
do the rap like you gotta put like
at least 95 percent in that [ __ ] yeah
you're saying like reinvest
your own money into your rapping yeah
put your money like reinvest your money
into your career like
because you got to show people that you
serious before they even willing to put
money
into you like most people like to be
like they'll go buy some cushion not
even want to go pay for studio time or
something like that like that should be
backwards but
yeah they'll go buy a 500 belt or get a
whole goddamn that's when i realized
like
i was doing [ __ ] backwards like when i
realized i was like hold up
man i got like a four five thousand
dollar outfit and i'm
i'm getting a thousand dollar video man
no i got to
flip that around yeah like that's if i'm
willing to spend this on
clothes i gotta be willing to spend
double that on something to take my
music career to the video to the next
level
exactly like but [ __ ] people don't be
understanding that but
[ __ ] they'll figure it out